after Ludwig's nuts got leaked yeah what  happened with that he pulled his nuts  out on cold ones to just be funny and  then uh Chad misunderstood in the edit  like he was like you want a blurred and  then he said he said LOL yeah but I  think Chad read it like sarcasm so it  was like dude you're a [ __ ] Legend  and then the nuts came out so it wasn't  like  with bad intentions no no no okay he  actually like mistook his meaning for a  long yeah yeah I mean I was reading he  had some big ass nuts Charlie did a  video and was like I feel like I pulled  my nuts out and they they wouldn't look  like that at all just looked like  [ __ ] just you know just like Harry  dates yeah  what was that that bacon  is this [ __ ] on cook what's going on  those are balls right there